المقابل كان بايدن قد عاد من
الشرق الاوسط فارغ اليدين. فهل
اقصى درجات حرارة في تاريخها حتى
ان سلاح الجو البريطاني اوقف
لوحوش قاسية وفتاكة. اكد نائب
وزير الدفاع الاوكراني ان
بالحرب وان المساعد الامريكية
احدثت فرقا كبيرا في المعارك. هل
بالعملة المحلية بما في ذلك
مشتريات الطاقة. اوكرانيا تقاتل
مدفوعات النفط من الهند بالدرهم
الاماراتي بدلا من الدولار
الصين ووحدة اراضيها. اجزاء من
بريطانيا تحترق. النيران تلتهم
والوعيد في خطابها للولايات
المتحدة. والسبب هذه المرة زيارة
بجنود معدلين وراثيا هذا ما صرحت
به موسكو موقع روسي كشف ان
الامريكي. تركيا ايضا تتطلع
للتخلي عن الدولار في مدفوعات
السابعة على روسيا في مراحلها
النهائية. بعد طلب روسيا تلقي
اوكرانيا تقوم بتجارب سرية لتحول
جنودها لالات بشرية خارقة. نائبة
الاصابة بسرطان الجلد خلال حديث
له عن الانبعاثات فيما قد يكون
هائل للقتلى الروس في حرب
اوكرانيا كشفته المخابرات
اوكرانيا بمهاجمة المنشآت
النووية وتحذر من كارثة. رقم
الامريكان صادقون باحصائياتهم
هذه? حزمة العقوبات الاوروبية
للبيت الابيض ينفي اصابة بايدن
بسرطان الجلد. روسيا تتهم
هذا التقرير اعلان وزير الدفاع
الامريكي عن رجوع كافة اوكرانيا
المركزية الامريكية قدرت عدد
قتلاهم بخمسة عشر الف قتيل وسبق
ولضرب الاساطيل البحرية يصل
مداها الى سبعة الاف كيلو متر.
تزويدها جوا. الاحداث والتطورات.
اصابة الرئيس الامريكي بفيروس
وهو ما يضع اوروبا والولايات
المتحدة ضمن مداها. ويمكن
كورونا والبيت الابيض يبث صورة
لبايدن ليثبت انه بصحة جيدة. لكن
وستون. الاضخم يلقبها الروس
بمفترسة السفن ويلقبها الناتو
اربعة وعشرين طنا من القنابل
القاذفة النووية الروسية مئة
في مدينة انشوان شمال غربي
البلاد. المصاب الذي عاد الى
على وتدل على عدم نية الدب
الروسي ايقاف الحرب وماذا عن
والبراغيث وحيوانات اخرى وليس له
علاج حاليا الا بالمضادات
اسهل. اما واشنطن فكان ردها فقط
ان زيارة بوتين الى ايران تدل
تركي على محافظة دهوك شمال
العراق. مصدر امني كردي قال ان
موسكو لتوسع الناتو في المنطقة.
صممت للفتك بالسفن المعادية
بوتين خرج من قمته مع تركيا
وايران باشياء ايجابية كثيرة. في
الرحلات باكبر قاعدة عسكرية له
لان الحر اذاب مدرج القاعدة.
مرتقبة لرئيسة مجلس النواب
الامريكي بيلوسي الى تايوان
وهي الدعوة نفسها التي وجهها
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
المنازل والسلطات تعلن حالة
الطوارئ القصوى. سجلت المملكة
قبل ذلك جو بايدن كان قد اثار
ضجة على السوشيال ميديا باعلانه
اغسطس المقبل. وقالت بكين زيارة
بيلوسي لتايوان صارخ لسيادة
الطاقة الروسية. يعمل البلدان
على اقتراح التجارة بينهما
على شبه جزيرة القرم باسلحة
غربية. الصين عادت للتهديد
رئيس مجلس الدوما زعمت تلقي
الجنود الاوكران لادوية حولتهم
اوكرانيا ستسحق الاسطول الروسي
في البحر الاسود وتستعيد السيطرة
اعلانه هذا زلة لسان او افصاحا
رسميا عن اصابته بالمرض وبيان
وصفه بالانتهاك السافر للسيادة
العراقية وطلب تركيا باعتذار
رئيس الوزراء العراقي مصطفى
الكاظمي اتهم تركيا بارتكاب ما
توترا مع بغداد. واردوغان يتعهد
بحل ملف حزب العمال الكردستاني.
ما يمكن ان يفعله العراق، وهنا
رد عراقي على استحياء بطائرات
رسمي وسحب قواتها من العراق
تطالبون باعتذار رسمي، هذا اقصى
الا تستحون يا هؤلاء كم سيتحمل
العراق طعنات وجراح. من جهتها
كردستان بين العراق وتركيا.
العمليات التركية في العراق تثير
البجعة البيضاء. يلقبها
العسكريون بالبجاعة البيضاء
تكشف تسجيل اول اصابة بالطاعون
الدبلي او ما يعرف بالموت الاسود
مرض معد يؤدي للوفاة ويأتي بسبب
بكتيريا تأتي من القوارض
الطاقة واغلق بعضها ثم اتهموا
شركة جاز بروم بالتسبب الازمة.
بحياة حوالي خمسين مليون شخص في
افريقيا واسيا واوروبا قديما وهو
تسعة اشخاص قتلوا في القصف الذي
اصاب منتجعا على الحدود باقليم
اطلقت الطارئة للوقاية من الوباء
والسيطرة عليه. مرض الطاعون اودى
الحيوية. العراق الجريح. عشرات
القتلى جرحى سقطوا في قصف صاروخي
الانتقام على ذلك الموقف بعد
مرور عامين كاملين لكن الدب
تستطيع حمل ما يزيد عن اثني عشر
صاروخا نوويا. والقاء ما يصل الى
انسحاب القوات الامريكية من
سوريا سيجعل مكافحة الارهاب
الايراني كذلك واشنطن بمغادرة
الاراضي السورية فورا ومن دون اي
التوجه لاخراج الامريكان يا ترى?
الجواب جاء من الرئيس التركي ان
بباك فاير. حلقت قرب شواطئ
السويد وفنلندا للتذكير بمعارضة
مسيرة استهدفت اماكن تواجد الجيش
التركي في الاراضي العراقية.
تركيا تنفي صلتها بالحادثة وتعلن
عن اسفها لمقتل المدنيين. وهنا
التركي رجب طيب اردوجان القوات
الامريكية الى مغادرة المناطق
المدينة كان قادما من مينغوليا
شمالي الصين. السلطات في المنطقة
لعبة هكذا انتشر الخبر بشكل كبير
على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي.
سوريا ايها الامريكان؟ وباء صيني
خطير. وكالة الانباء الصينية
الطوارئ وتطلب النجدة وبوتين
يظهر بمفترسة السفن وكييف تهدد
الرئيس التركي وتقدم بوتين خطوات
ليسلم عليه. هل اراد اردوغان
بضرب اسطول موسكو البحري. لعبة
الانتظار. الانتظار للانتقام صار
متهما واشنطن بسرقة النفط الروسي
وبيعه في الخارج. لماذا كل هذا
تقاتل بجنود معدلين وراثيا. ما
هذا الرعب؟ وبريطانيا تعلن
خطير يصيب الرئيس الامريكي. فما
هو المرض الذي قد يودي بحياته
لتغيير التعامل بالدولار خارجيا.
فهل هي خطة من موسكو؟ اوكرانيا
شيء بانفسهم. واوضح بوتين ان
الغرب فرض عقوبات على خطوط نقل
تركيا وايران وسوريا. الجميع
يقولها بصوت واحد على امريكا
علاقة جاز بروم بذلك؟ ما
علاقتها؟ لقد اغلقتم خطا ثم
الروسي لذلك? القمة الثلاثية. في
قمتهم الثلاثية دعا الرئيس
لكن زعيم روسيا عاد وهدد بقطع
الغاز عن اوروبا. فهل يخطط الدب
الشمس وطاقة الرياح. لكنه اتضح
انه شتاء طويل وليس هناك رياح.
الواقعة شرقي نهر الفرات في
سوريا وطالب وزير الخارجية
بروم مستعدة لضخ اكبر قدر ممكن
من الغاز لكن الغرب اغلقوا كل
الروسي جعل اردوغان ينتظر اكثر
من مرة ولوقت اطول في كل مرة.
سخرية بوتين. هم قرروا الاعتماد
على الطاقة غير التقليدية مثل
هكذا سخر بوتين من قادة اوروبا.
الرئيس الروسي اضاف متسائلا
اغلقتم خطا اخر وفرضتم عقوبات
على محطات ضخ الغاز. شركة جاز
نظيره التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
للاجتماع به على هامش قمة طهران
اشارة غير واضحة تحمل نوعا من
العتاب على التأخير. هناك وصل
لمدة قاربت الدقيقة مع علامات
الملل التي بدت واضحة عليه. وفي
وصف تركي جديد على العراق وتوعد
عراقي بالرد وباء صيني جديد
اثارت ضجة اعلامية كبيرة ظهر
بوتين خلال مقطع فيديو وهو ينتظر
بعد ان عاش الرئيس الروسي لحظات
ثقيلة امام الكاميرات. القصة
وخطير. هل هي جائحة اخرى يا
اصحاب العيون الضيقة؟ تركيا تتجه
مغادرة سوريا. هل هو تحالف من
نوع جديد يطلقه الدب الروسي؟ مرض
هل هو الانتقام من الرئيس التركي
لما حصل له من قبل؟ اغلقوا خطوط
الغاز ويبحثون عن المذنب. هكذا
سخر بوتين من اوروبا وقادتها.
هكذا انتظر اردوجان بطريقة مخجلة
اليوم وبعد ثلاث سنوات يتكرر
المشهد ولكن بطريقة معاكسة.
صارت الكفة راجحة لصالح الروس?